well today is World Braille day and to
celebrate a unique art installation is
being opened in London visitors to the
power of church will wear special
glasses so they can experience the
distinctive umbrella in much the same
way as a blind or partially sighted
person would now the artist behind the
exhibition Clark Reynolds joins us now
very pleased to have you here Clark good
morning to you happy New Year happy New
Year happy world Broadway tell us a
little bit about this exhibition uh so
the exhibition is at Qantas Gallery
um down fashion Street in London and
it's my first ever solo exhibition in
London
um and power touch literally says what's
on the tin
um you know when you go into galleries
there's always big signs saying don't
touch the art but in my exhibitions
there's signs saying do touch the art
and you exported to becoming a child
again and that's really important with
my the idea of engaging with the art
taking you back to somewhere that's
happier times so talk to us about that
then so you can get up up close Hands-On
so and and feel through to talk to us
about the work then so what is it yeah
Braille artist
um ironically do you call me like a brow
typographer so typographers work with
letters I work with dots literally as
you can see on what I'm wearing and the
idea is as a such a person it's visually
stunning so you'll look at it and there
is a code people get codes so you can
actually decode what's what's written
and then you decipher it uh with your
with your you know with your friends or
your siblings uh your children because
children love the coding and then as a
blind person we can physically go up and
touch the whole work and it becomes you
can actually decode it through touch
um so it's like it Bridges the gap
between tactile and a visual world and
obviously this is the first kind of
exhibition of its kind like this is it
or is or have you done this this sort of
thing before to have it be so sort of um
interactive for people in fact my art
way is always interactive so last uh
couple years
um I've had solo shows in the South I'm
from Portsmouth so I've had shows uh
aspects Gallery at yellow Edge Gallery
and the base in Newbury but this anyone
who's an artist you know site or
non-sighted the dream is to exhibit in
London it always has been it's it's the
the mecca for the art world so if this
is my first solo show at Qantas and I
hope what I want to show is someone like
myself who has a disability or has the
word blindness front and still can still
co-exist in mainstream art that's so
important to me because unfortunately
what I do even because I've got the word
disability or blindness in front of me
it's seen as a hobby that's how Society
sees me in the creative industry so what
Qantas is doing is showing the world
that a blind person can compete with the
likes of Damian Hurst Tracy Yemen
Anthony Gormley why do you think that is
why do you think that it's still not
your work isn't I mean those are
obviously amazing artists yeah we're
going to put you in the same category as
them why not not yet exactly why not why
not exactly I've been told through a
whole my whole life I grew up in a
council state I grew up without culture
I grew up without those connections in
the art world I was told I could never
be an artist you know a loss my sight
can I be an artist you know so is this
always something that you wanted to do
always from the age of six there was no
other career for me I I lost my sight of
my right eye from age six I um I went to
a gallery and I knew from then at age
six I wanted to be an artist I knew you
know I'd done a deep down inside I knew
um unfortunately I left school and my
teens due to bad kidneys but I'm a
fighter I got back into higher education
I got my degree in our degree in model
making and then nine years ago I started
Elizabeth so I had to give up my career
as a dental model maker but it wasn't
like oh my God I'm going blind it was
like right I'm going to be that artist I
always want to be as that six-year-old
and that brings us back to the art that
I do now I want that that experience no
matter your age to go to this exhibition
that Qantas and to experience it as a
six-year-old if that makes sense yeah of
course it does of course it's because is
it the sort of the naive brain is able
to really connect with things in ways
that adults when we rationalize and try
and analyze things too much we often
can't do that's right it's people think
that you can't appreciate art if you
don't understand that you know you know
the idea of having an art history oh god
I've got really understand what what
this banana is representing you know but
for me art is for everyone you know and
breaking down boundaries with my art and
have a conversations that we're having
right now I mean the best thing for me
that I've done
you know the art is great but the best
thing is I go into a lot of schools I
engage with over a thousand children and
I teach Braille and then I talk about
sight loss because let's start breaking
down barriers of sight loss and what
sight loss is that's okay if we can
change those perception that next
generation of children going up then the
stigma attached to me will never happen
to the Next Generation official paid
children growing up and that's so
important and talk to us about that
important thing about you know being
able to overcome those challenges and
also sort of serving as an inspiration
to people to see what you can achieve
even if
um barriers are put in your way
but the barriers that I put them away is
what Society tells me what I can do as a
blind person officially the only thing I
can't do is a blind person is Drive even
though I've got a driving license I can
still probably drive a car but
officially I can't do it I mean I've
jumped out of a plane
I played blind Cricket for Hampshire and
Sussex I was hoping batsman you know
when England was playing really rubbish
yeah I I thought there was a time they
should have picked me really
um so I I've embraced it's really weird
I've embraced the word blindness I love
being a blind because I'm see I'm making
a difference now the best thing could
have happened to me was a couple years
ago I did a braille Trail at Victorious
huge music festival you imagine 50 000
people
um I was working with a team called
Seekers we did a braille trail and I I
walk around this yellow suit hand out
Maps my wife came
and a young girl came up to me with her
dad and the dad says we can this young
girl touch my suit of course so I got my
knees she's about yeah High about five
years old and then the dad asked the
girl why do you want to touch the man's
suit and and the girl her name was Etta
she says um daddy because I'm blind
and we had the most amazing conversation
you know she lived locally she comes to
all my my exhibitions and that young
girl changed my life how I saw right
this is what I'm gonna do I want to be
an inspiration for her so that she sees
me in working in this creative industry
or doing things that a blind person
should be doing and that way she can
turn around to a parent and say you know
what I'm gonna do that because Clark can
do that you said that embarrassing
between you in your way by Society do
you think that's still the case now with
a similar agent and I wonder how it's
been sort of going through through life
how do you feel like it's changed you
know 2023 now things are meant to be
more open for people who aren't you know
the status quo it's really strange
obviously it's that kind of postcode
lottery I think it is in a way obviously
I'm from Portsmouth and then when I go
to when I travel and I do things I look
at how the access is in that in that
place and for me important if I want
trying to make it the most accessible
inclusive place in the city to get
around to get around yeah and also
Braille we go back to browse like I
learned Braille
but I can't physically use braille if
that makes sense right I can't go to a
restaurant and after a brown menu yeah I
I can't toilets the toilets you know the
easiest thing to put Braille on right I
could put my hand out and it's like if
that's a male a female unisex disabled
but I can't and a lot of people Vision
pay people go into the wrong gender
toilet it's so embarrassing
why isn't there a brayer there and why
is Braille that small dot make it big
make it bold use speed read yeah I can
speed touch right you know let's embrace
the power of the dot and that's the
beauty of what Mark does and hopefully
when people come to the exhibition at
Qantas next week and for the next month
They Come Away with a feel of I've
learned something because I make you
work for my art there's nothing wrong
with that working and learning a little
something in Clark Rentals we really
love to speak to you it's been fantastic
you've got the program out there as well
so people hopefully will be going to the
exhibition starting next week thank you
very much for coming in really
appreciate it thank you